Johnny welcome to a theory of everything
into the day everyone relax
it's actually kind of torture to make
the introvert wait to the very end of
the day to actually give their talk but
actually think it's somewhat appropriate
today given sort of the nature of what
I'm gonna be talking about it's a bit
and introspective so you're a special
bunch to actually show up today and help
me talk about this cool any physicists
in the house okay I'm sorry
in advance it's like three three or four
this for you cool so so we're gonna be
talking about a theory of everything
this is something that's been rolling
around in my head for about a about a
year or so right now basically referring
to how I like to view the software world
and the things that I see as my journey
from an engineer to a senior engineer
and also to a manager and about the
interactions I have with people when I
teach people how to code through things
like General Assembly and black girls
code and things of that nature and I'm
trying to explain things that seem very
weird to me and so this is my attempt to
do that so a little bit about me my name
is Johnny
I'm recursive funk most things on the
web
I leave the directions team at map box
for those who don't know map box is a
data location platform basically if you
want to build any sort of location-aware
functionality within your applications
whether it be turn by turn directions
geocoding embedded maps etc you can come
to us for that that's not what I'm here
to talk about today if you want to talk
about that
tap me later so a brief history of me
and like why I choose to like talk about
something like this my early career was
in government contracting and you know
my first job was sort of the j2ee
enterprise systems right and going to
school for college and for computer
science you know I graduated I had my
fancy degree I did the white board dance
answered the trivial
all that good stuff that was expected of
me but I didn't really know how to be a
software engineer and so a lot of what I
saw at the time colored my experience
for the rest of my career and so for
those who you know remember a Java
server pages I spent a lot of time in
those right those who don't know I heard
some Google's you know for those who
don't know it's basically just a way to
sort of like tie in server-side
rendering java applications with
JavaScript on the front end I spent a
lot of time and knows and initially it
just didn't click with me that some
stuff was happening on the server some
stuff was happening on the client it was
very very common to have this really
weird
spaghetti mutated code that had a few
lines of Java followed by a few lines of
like jQuery or something like that and
as a junior engineer this was just like
the way things were done didn't occur to
me that things could be done better
obviously I learned at some point that
you know the dynamics of this is not
quite what its seen but it didn't really
change anything I imagine it's a lot
like being dropped on your head or
something at an early age right just
survived it but it does change you a
little bit so in physics a theory of
everything essentially refers to yet to
be discovered theory that combines all
of the things we know about reality
right so in the macro world we have
things like you and I buildings planets
stars etc that are governed by classical
physics you know the rules of gravity
laws of thermodynamics things like that
right we all understand this stuff we
learned in grade school was very
intuitive to us as human beings but in
the quantum realm for those our into the
Marvel movies these days things behave
very differently I don't want to get
into like the very specifics of it but
things that we take for granted such as
time right and where things are in space
those sort of questions and observations
become somewhat nonsensical
at the quantum level and that's I'll
stop right there because that is not my
expertise at all so the idea is that in
one area of the universe we have a set
of rules and from another perspective we
have a completely different set of rules
they're largely incompatible at face
value but we just have to accept the
fact that when you're dealing with
certain size you're dealing with certain
set of rules a theory of everything
attempts to combine them together in
such a way that makes it elegant to
explain everything regardless of the
size so that's what we depart the world
of the physics and talk about software
what do I mean by a theory of everything
within software development well I want
to talk about or at least explore how we
can start to unify and unite all aspects
of software development very very
broadly I'll be talking about front end
back in you know I'm basically referring
to servers and browsers but things today
are like very very complex you know 2018
you know what the heck is a full stack
developer anyway these are very
complicated things and so the things
that I observe throughout my career have
me questioning like why aren't we are
aren't we more unified right I didn't
really meet someone who described
themselves at a front-end developer
until I was almost a senior engineer
right and you know I didn't I didn't
know what this person was talking about
you know a front-end developer like what
the hell is that
you write jQuery like 24/7 like what is
that not disparaging jQuery I learned
JavaScript through jQuery but it just it
was very nonsensical to me it didn't
make any sense at all right the idea
that you would write some code on the
front end and then write some code in
the back end and wrangle some
infrastructure to me that was just the
way this was done I didn't see very much
distinction about like I specialize here
or there and so thus my journey to try
to figure out why everyone thought one
way and I was thinking about another so
why would I even try to talk about this
like why is this even a big deal right
well there are consequences of
compartmentalization we already see them
right the more tangible ones you know
silo teams
prevents good cohesive communication and
obviously it helps us rinse us from
shipping as often as we want right
everyone knows that it becomes really
tricky to hire and also train new
developers particularly when you're
talking about junior people right having
a cohesive way to talk about your
systems in such a way that doesn't see
people sort of like falling off the ship
you know as you go along the stack and
people sort of like checking out right
when I run department meetings and there
are people from all across the stack in
there you know there's been like issues
where it's like oh we talked about too
much front end in this meeting or we
talk about too much front end back in or
why don't we keep talking about AWS in
this meeting you know it's all relevant
to the things that we do and so that was
always the thing that bugged me
Occupational demagoguery I saw that from
a co-worker you know this idea that like
front end is like the easy stuff right
and if you ever tried to build a
non-trivial front-end these days you
know that that's ridiculous back-end is
for like programmers or whatever and
infrastructure wrangling is for like
antisocial neckbeards and stuff like
that ridiculous stuff but I mean there's
definitely a x' a segment of our
population and actually you know holds
true to these to these stereotypes there
are benefits of unification quite simply
a common language
maybe not specific nomenclature but a
common way of thinking about how we
approach systems the things that we
value the things that we think are
important when we're actually building
things it provides the easier path of
mobility across the stack for individual
employees people who want to like
actually do and work on front-end stuff
we've never actually you know dip their
toe in that world and vice versa and
people want to go back the other way and
obviously empathy is a really good
benefit to all of this so taking a step
back why aren't we there yet
certainly software engineering is not as
mature as physics itself but certainly
we've been at this for for a while and
there's still a bit of splintering and
compartmentalization
one thing that happened is that front
end just just blew up in complexity
right you know we were building stuff
first of all we had script tags and then
like those went out the window then we
had grunt and then grunt was like not
enough and then we had gulp which was
crazy because then we were like using
streams all over the place then we went
to wet pack and I just got really crazy
and you know people were like this is
insane too much complexity and doing
everything in MPM scripts and we like to
one-up each other so then people were
like I'm going back to make files can
you beat that
I know you're in here somewhere
and then transpilers and pre-processors
and packages and minifiers and source
maps and linters and it got so crazy we
need to create like CL is just like help
us do this stuff right because all the
overhead required just to get a static
website up and going it's it's bananas
it's crazy out there
you know kind of feel like this
sometimes browsers
well browsers are interesting they're no
longer just document parsers right there
are platforms in and of themselves you
have user interface with HTML and CSS ok
JSX
for those folks rich-media me we got
this with html5 and audio and video you
can do databases in the browser with web
sequel real-time updates and data
strings with WebSockets
peer-to-peer communication with WebRTC
data channels which is really cool
multi-threading of sorts with web
workers gaming immersive worlds with
WebGL need 3d programmers in the
audience you folks are crazy just
kidding you're you're amazing offline
capabilities notifications unfortunately
and frameworks that let you sort of like
wire all these things together in such a
way that's pretty cohesive on the other
side
servers have gotten really simple right
the abstraction just keep getting better
right you know we had hardware like vm's
and we started wrangling themes and then
we threw them in a cloud to make them
someone else's problem and then they
were like well I don't want to deal with
this so like boom we have containers and
then someone was like I just want to
function right which is great a lot of
business logic today can be distilled
down into just a few functions and then
you use services for everything else and
infrastructure itself got really
declarative you just tell AWS or Google
cloud like what you want and they'll
just like do it for you and everything
is service based right not talking about
micro services I just mean like hosted
services how many conversations have you
had where you were trying to choose the
best streaming processing framework and
it was like down the Kinesis or Kafka
and then you chose Kinesis simply
because it's a hosted thing in AWS and
you have to worry about it
right that's a completely valid reason
to choose that technology so what's
happening well Brendon was straight up
script tags and now we have these
complex spill pup
pipelines in the backend used to be
complex and now it's just to collecting
the functions and external resources so
we've certainly started moving towards
each other some would say we've sort of
walked past each other a bit but there's
still a big gap right we still don't
like really talk to each other in the
way that you know is very productive you
can comfortably devote your entire
career just doing front-end and you
don't have to even think about the
backend too much if you don't want to so
why why is there a gap JavaScript
promises were made then nothing catch my
drift
that's it good night just kidding okay
you all are smart Bunch I almost took
this out I wasn't sure but there was a
real promise for those of us who were
doing this when nodejs first came out I
mean that was it that was that was the
end-all be-all like all the JavaScript
developers were like like we're done
like we have all the jobs ever no one is
ever gonna hire anyone else this is it
and it didn't quite work out that way
frameworks like next and nuts sort of
got us closer there's still a lot of
work to do for those who don't know next
Jas is a web application framework that
you know allows you to do react
server-side rendering and next is its
counterpart on the view JSI which begs a
question is JavaScript too useful when
you can do anything people will do
everything right it's everywhere
just look at browsers not to beat up on
browsers or anything but I mean
javascript is all over the place and
better devices system utilities it's
absolutely everywhere you can't you
can't get away from it so is it too
useful I don't think so I think we have
a lot of surface area but I think that
that allows us to have more
specialization right one could take a
trip in react land and never actually
see a server crash like that's the thing
people can do that there's there's that
much to do there and you can start with
writing cloud formation templates
wrangling infrastructure and never
actually perform a Dom query anytime in
your entire career I feel like the
ladder is more common in the than the
former and the fact that you can use
JavaScript to do either one of these is
absolutely meaningless it means nothing
so what I'm trying to say is programming
language is not the great unifier
despite all the best efforts it's like
some really brilliant people out there
and a lot of work going into a lot of
frameworks I just don't see it I don't
see it panning out and my day to day
work I don't see it you know with any of
my direct reports or any of the people
I've ever worked with I still get the
same sort of no I'm react front-end like
I don't touch that note stuff and the
same thing with people who program a
node like I don't I don't do front-end
stuff you know I'm not a designer I'm
like well that's not really a thing but
anyway so what is the great unifier if
we can't count on our programming
languages to sort of bridge the gap then
how can we do it right aliens just
kidding values values are a much
stronger conduit for allowing aligning
people and technology in such a way that
allows us to work together more
productively the number one question I
get from beginner programmers is which
programming language should I learn
first everyone asks this whether it's
teaching a boot camp or a summer camp or
just people starting out everyone asks
this held my lyft driver asked me this
right my response is like it doesn't
matter like it literally just does not
matter if you ignore factors like
geographical location in the job market
and all this other stuff it just doesn't
matter at all you could plot all the
common programming languages JavaScript
Python Go Java etc on a board and cover
your eyes and throw a dart and whichever
one it hits you can go learn that and
have a career right it doesn't really
matter so what do you make what what do
I mean when I say values well values can
really be anything it's up to you to
actually decide that it's up to you to
come to an alignment about what are the
things you think are most important when
you want to actually build a team build
a system and think about the things that
are going to help you be successful
declarative over imperative right a
react component state definition is on
the opposite end of the stack as a
CloudFormation template but they feel
very complimentary right
you're not accomplishing the same goal
but you're doing it in very much the
same way you're telling you know the
universe like this is how I want my
application to be this is the state that
I wanted in and then there's some you
know some dancing around about changes
in state and whatnot but it's very much
the same thing someone who is doing one
can very much understand the importance
of the pattern in doing the other this
is the big one composition over
inheritance right if you can internalize
a designer's process of creating a
composable interface in the process of
taking smaller pieces combining them
with bigger ones to create new
components and then taking the bigger
components and combining them to create
new pages if you can internalize why
that's important and why that's useful
then there's no reason why you can't
internalize why go Lang's interfaces are
really powerful at least in the way that
they implement them convention over
configuration if anyone's ever poked
around in a rails app I mean you know
you've seen one you've seen them all
and that's not a bad thing right you
know where to go to see everything and
it's that same principle that allows you
to recognize why and not be created
using an angular si CLI is navigable in
much the same way they don't have to be
these fancy computer science design
patterns either right you know you can
say you know we value users over
everything else right and when you groom
your team and your company to sort of
like think this way to think in terms of
users and what's really important to
them
you sort of train people to view the
world that way and so it's not a stretch
to say that well most of the time a
database query you know is is an act of
creating a user experience right most of
the time we're optimizing for speed
memory consumption etc and say you can
say well that's more related to cost but
at the very same time you know what is
the consequence of that query like
what's what's happening when it
done right there's someone waiting for
it somewhere even if it's not immediate
it goes to another subsystem that
subsystem runs a report does a thing a
job bla bla bla
if it's not making its way to a user
even if that user is another developer
then I don't know how you're making
money honestly
so what are your values this is your job
you have to figure out what's important
to you what's important to your team
your company and the things that you
need to figure out in order to make
yourselves successful it's the only way
to ensure that you have the right
alignment choosing a new technology is
kind of like hiring a new person right
your team is gonna spend a lot of time
with this tech step you want to make
sure it's the right one and you want to
make sure obviously you get pert someone
who's qualified for the job but also you
want to make sure someone is aligned
with your values the ones you set forth
in your company as well and choosing
technology is very much the same way you
make sure it can solve your root problem
but at the very same time make sure that
it aligns with the values that you've
set for thing that you decided is
important values as a universal language
choose and write values can be a tricky
proposition there's a lot of
back-and-forth about you know what
people think is important what they
think is not important or ridiculous or
silly one thing that I really like to
talk about is one of Matt box's core
values and that's to debate decide and
commit it gives everyone a voice to talk
about what they think is extremely
important to have a voice and to be able
to have that voice be heard no matter
who they are whether it's a VP or a
junior software engineer then a decision
is made right someone has to be
accountable for that decision making
sure that you have accountability about
this is very very important and that's
not enough a lot of decisions get made
and they get
Wiki somewhere no one ever gets to look
at it right the commit part is the most
important part making sure that the team
commits to this making sure that when
you go out and you're doing code reviews
and you're building things and
everything that you want to have go into
the productivity of your team always
comes down to the things that you've
committed to putting it in action that's
that's the most important part and it's
also a good framework framework for
creating new values chickened out at the
last minute and so instead of saying
like a theory of everything I'm just
gonna put my theory specialization is
okay that's fine there's nothing wrong
with that there's nothing wrong with the
the smorgasbord of JavaScript frameworks
and back in programming languages and
different web application frameworks and
cloud providers and all this other stuff
as long as we don't compartmentalize
that's that's the part that's gonna you
know be the end of us we can specialize
but as long as we have shared values we
can communicate effectively and we can
exchange ideas and in this way we can
make each other better
programming language unification is a
myth do not drink the kool-aid right
there are a lot of people out there who
have been programming JavaScript for a
very long time but I've never touched a
server and that's okay there's just way
too much surface area even disparate
versions within the same programming
language is problematic you know look at
Python 3 and ES 20 whatever values
alignment is the unifying language
that's gonna allow us to sort of move
this industry forward and it works for
people too Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
happy to take questions if not I'll be
around all day you have a question over
here oh yeah
so the question was do I find that
different values in across different
stacks are related to object-oriented
programming or other values it can be
they a lot of times they are because
that's that's what I view is like the
low-hanging fruit because those are the
things you can hit the ground running
with you know you have certain values
because these are things that people
take into consideration when they're
creating programming languages or when
they're like establishing a baseline of
like this is how you're productive in
this particular language and so like yes
those the easy ones that do urge people
to sort of think beyond that a bit you
know and we when we start to talk about
what's a design pattern and what's not
things get a little bit blurry I don't
know if TVB test-driven development is
necessarily a design pattern but it's
like something that I would consider a
strong value to take into consideration
and making sure that when you're
choosing the right technologies that you
know if that's a way you want to go make
sure you do it in such a way that
supports that particular value anything
else yes
yeah yeah so the question was how do you
establish values from the bottom up if
you have no authority to tell someone
what a value is how does that happen
it's actually a really good question a
few years ago when I was a technology
director at an agency we decided that we
needed some values for the engineering
team and it wasn't a process where I got
in a room and sit like these are our
values so we went through some very
rapid cycles of the debate decide and
commit it got a bit heated people have
very strong feelings about this sort of
thing as it turns out but I think it's
work that needs to be done so if this is
something that needs to happen I think
that well first of all just because you
don't manage people you don't have any
official power doesn't mean you can't
lead an effort right you can be a leader
without necessarily having Authority in
fact that's the best type of leader if
you want to lead something like this
within your company I encourage you to
do so like tell people like get you know
your fellow ICS together like leave the
managers out of it they've you know
sometimes we're useless don't worry
about it
get the ICS together you know you all
debate decide and commit what you think
the value should be because you're the
ones on the ground every day actually
doing the work actually doing the
implementation you're the ones who have
to be productive and so you know better
than anyone else you know who should
actually be doing this when we did it I
facilitated the conversations the team
actually decided what the values were in
fact I think that probably best that it
comes from the engineers and designers
on the ground rather than from
management yes
thank you
right
yep the question was how often should
you review your values that's a really
good question uh I don't know it
probably differs from company to company
I mean I suppose you can roughly align
it with say you're a start-up right I
guess you can roughly align it with the
growth of your company whether it's and
you know investments or if you've gotten
to a new stage of company size but then
again you know some values I think
should stay rooted regardless of the
company size I think that they should
stick around for as long as they
possibly can the way you implement them
may change depending on you know the
size of the company and you know what
the company needs but if you're changing
values often um in my mind that means
the company itself is just changing at
that point you have to decide if you're
a different company than when you were
when you start it and that's ok if you
are but you know you have to have a very
honest conversation about that so short
answer is not very often at all because
then you have to update the website
yep sure oh yeah and there's probably
we're probably talking about two
separate things right so your people
values I mean that's that's definitely
one thing that you should think about
but I think that you should have a very
specific set of values that are
associated with how you choose different
technologies and they change at
different rates I think your technology
values are gonna change much more often
than your people values are I mean
things get rewritten all the time you
know refactor Zrii rights etc even when
you're changing implementing
technologies but I don't necessarily
think that that's cause for a change in
values if what you have is working you
know I don't want to tell you to like
run your business differently at all yes
in the back here
yeah so the question is how do you
onboard people to those values
essentially I mean it's really important
I mean you just be straight up at the
very beginning so map box I think has
probably one of the best engineering
onboarding processes I've seen in my
career it's essentially a mini boot camp
and in addition to being on board you
know your AWS creds and all this other
stuff slack etc etc values are part of
that right and people know what they are
I mean you don't get like quizzed
earning at least I don't think you get
quizzed or anything but you know you get
the history of it and people know
exactly what they are and why they exist
I think it's important to maintain your
company's history the onboarding process
as well showing how you got to a place
is as important as the end result itself
because a lot of times it changes you
know your way of thinking how many times
have you dived into a new codebase and
you're like why the hell if they do it
this way but someone told you oh we did
this then we did this and then we did
this and you were like oh I would have
done the exact same thing so I think
that's really important yes how do you
resolve the conflict between efficiency
and communication that's a separate talk
yeah I mean I don't think that there is
a resolution to speak of I think there's
probably a balance that we all need to
maintain and that's definitely gun
that's gonna be different for for every
company you know how you communicate map
box is probably more distributed than
most companies but probably not as
distributed say like a github or
something like that and so our the way
we approach communication efficiency is
much different everything has to be
asynchronous because when you're working
someone you work with is probably
sleeping and so that makes a big
difference on the things that we sort of
like value in terms of like what we do
and how we make sure we communicate
effectively yes
right so in the case of a my previous
employer that was like an all that once
thing but that was that was a little bit
different that was a special situation
you know we were transitioning from more
or less a a CMS shop to an actual sort
of like product development engineering
team and we knew at that time we needed
to sort of like a buy buy a new set of
values but I think that with most
companies this is gonna happen over time
because I mean even if you do it upfront
you're not gonna get it right I mean you
don't even know if the product you're
building is gonna be the same product in
two to three years let alone the things
that you value so I think they have to
change over time you have to be amenable
to it but I think once you hit that that
sort of that product group I think your
your values should follow along with
that and sure you should be relatively
stable way in the back over here
mm-hmm so if I understand your question
correctly is if you're a small
department within a larger company like
how do you use this paradigm to actually
I guess integrate with the values of the
company overall is that the question
okay um I'm very carefully that's a
really good question you know I guess
I'm sick of saying it depends but it
really does depend on the company itself
like who you are within that company and
you know what is the the culture of
being accepting of that sort of thing I
mean I could think of a couple companies
that would like strike you down with all
the force you know but as long as you
know there is a willingness to actually
do this then you know another another
value MapBox has is JFDI
can I curse on here just [ __ ] do it
right just do it I think what you'll
find is that if you're right and if you
have good results other people will
follow when we did this years ago not a
matte box but at the other company we
were just the first you know we
presented our values you know this has
no conflict with the company itself and
its goals this is how we're gonna do it
and sure enough people were like damning
me on slack like how'd you do that you
know can I do that with my team I'm like
yeah you sure can and so everyone like
came up with their own values we did
talk to make sure that we were aligned
so like you know we didn't have like
conflicting values or anything like that
but that was very much part of the
process I'd say just do it and watch
people follow suit yes that's a good
question how many values should you have
I like
five ish I really don't like to get more
than like five or six more than that
it's kind of pushing it the idea is that
value should be whenever someone makes a
decision in the company I think that
they should be able to quickly scan all
of the values mentally if you have too
many people can't do that right and
that's not to say if you have a list of
values that if it's larger than six that
you failed necessarily it just means
that you're gonna have a harder time
getting people to really internalize
those so I think five or six is just
enough to actually it's actually how
help your employees like internalize
this and help them apply it to every
decision they make I use to work at
Capital One I think they have like two
values which is kind of crazy but it's
kind of cool because like no matter what
I'm doing like I can always like call up
the values mentally any other questions
yes
sure the question is how do you use
values in the hiring process so that you
don't end up within a homogeneous
workplace right so I think values are
the thing that actually counteract that
right the other side of that is like
culture fit right that's not what I'm
talking about cultural fit is like the
thing that you know brings people in and
say oh I can have a beer with this
person and so that's when you start to
bring people in who are look and behave
exactly like you do values are much more
important because it's not something
that's internal to the person values are
external right it's a thing that we all
agree upon it's like objective reality
whereas like culture fit is about like
who you are you know and that's the
thing that's very dangerous you know
culture fit could be like you know I
like to drink beer or something like
that oh you're gonna fit in well here
because we have free beer 24/7 where is
like a value maybe something like you
know we don't know we value results more
than hard work right that's about a
thing that you do in a result that you
achieve and so regardless of where
person came from what they like what
they don't like how they grew up how
much money they had as long as they
believed in that thing and they can move
towards that then that's great
because it has nothing to do with them
as a person whereas like all of a sudden
you're filtering out people based on you
know whether or not they like stella's
or something right Estella's are great
by the way yes
do I have an advice from when teams
values clash with larger organization
well first I would say if the
organization already has values strongly
consider just using those you know
everyone's not gonna have the autonomy
to create like a subculture and like sub
team values and whatnot I would say that
please try and prevent that at all costs
that's gonna cause a lot of problems but
if they do clash then obviously that's
gonna force a conversation right you
know who's right you know if we have
contradictory values then we have to
have a very honest conversation about
are the company values out of line with
like the people we've hired now and like
this is a better way forward then that's
a conversation or if you as an
individual team create values that are
contradictory then you know I can
imagine that you know to your boss you
just seem like insubordinate so a
conversation anything else yes
yeah I mean that's a good question so
the question is values a very abstract
how do you quantify alignment that's up
to you so this is hard work this is not
easy you don't like scribble values down
and be like boom we're aligned it's
important part of the process of
deciding like what things you value and
then deciding how does that translate to
the work that you do every day
and that's a really hard process it's
like you said you you can't really truly
quantify it it's like trying to quantify
a developer's productivity right you
start pulling these numbers Lao such as
such had this number of commits etc etc
you can learn something but you'll never
actually learn how productive that
person is if they didn't commit Co for
three weeks but they solve one of the
biggest problems I mean it just doesn't
make sense so unfortunately I don't have
any easy answers it's a case-by-case
basis figure out the things that you
value then begins the really really hard
work of figuring out if this actually
aligns with what you're trying to do
that's it all right thanks everyone
[Applause]